teachers praying on students the rich
praying on the poor Barney Stinson
praying on anything that moves sexual
scenarios between people of radically
different ages are always tough to watch
Julie Cooper certainly isn't winning any
parent of the Year Awards for her
behavior in the first few seasons of The
OC however sleeping with Luke her
daughter Marissa's ex was a particularly
awful move on her part at the time Julie
is going through a bit of an identity
crisis following her husband's loss of
their family fortune through Brad losing
as much money as I have is
uh not an impressive accomplishment
wanting to recapture her discarded youth
she decides to get in bed with her
daughter's high school sweetheart
Marissa is already having a rough go of
things between her mom's unhinged
behavior and her dad's Scandal and this
Sly move certainly doesn't help instead
of coming clean to her daughter Julie
leaves Marissa to discover the truth
when she overhears Luke promising
Marissa's current boyfriend Ryan that
he's ending things with Julie not only
does Marissa feel the sting of betrayal
from Julie and Luke she feels blindsided
by Ryan who kept the truth from her to
be fair Ryan is the one who makes sure
both parties stop the illicit Affair and
it's easy to understand why he feels
this is a secret best left unsaid but
the truth always comes out in Orange
County as he should already know while
the show does confirm that Luke is 18
before he and Julie hook up it doesn't
make this extremely contentious scenario
between a mother and a high schooler any
less
creepy while any Rel relationship
between a professor and a student is
fundamentally inappropriate what's
particularly disconcerting about the
relationship between Professor Asher
Fleming and Paris Geller is how
normalized it is before he and Geller
get together Fleming has already built a
reputation for manipulating a new girl
into an affair every year from the very
first time Rory Witnesses the duo
kissing outside their dorm nothing is
easy to watch about their relationship
thankfully at least some of the
characters who aren't Paris Fleming or
Fleming Starstruck students are
horrified at the very mention of the
affair what's worse Fleming has little
to fear despite the illegality of this
situation the tenured Yale Professor
knows that if he's caught the school
will probably just sweep the Scandal
under the rug in fact his relationship
with Paris was so public that when he
ultimately dies of a heart attack Paris
informs Rory that she has actually
become the proprietor of his estate and
is communicating directly with Fleming's
family if friends teaches us anything
it's to avoid lying about your age
Monica learns this lesson the hard way
when she fibs about being 22 to a
gentleman CER she believes to be in
college sadly for her he also lies about
his age and in the episode the one with
the I factor Monica winds up hooking up
with a 17-year-old as a result of course
there are plenty of questionable
scenarios throughout friend's run but
this situation is pushing it even by
classic sitcom standards not only is
this age Gap uncomfortable it's illegal
even more disturbing Monica only learns
the truth after they've done the deed
and fans have to witness way too much of
her massively inappropriate EX change
with the teenager you're not a senior oh
I'm a senior Monica at least feels gross
about it but the one episode inclusion
is wholly unnecessary later in the show
Frank and Alice's relationship presents
similar ickiness Phoebe's brother is
freshly 18 when he dates 44-year-old
Alice not only do they get married way
too quickly and ask Phoebe to serve as a
surrogate they also have a horrifyingly
intense PDA problem the cringe doesn't
end there though Ross later dates a
student from his NYU class and Monica
has a long-term relationship with an
older family friend who knew her as a
child while many of the situations and
friends wouldn't exist on TV today the
show's approach to age Gap relationships
is especially
off-putting there are many aspects of
Glee that have aged poorly and many of
them involve the show's bad boy Noah
Puck Puckerman however of all the
devious circumstances Puck enters
throughout the series his relationship
with Shelby Corran Takes the Cake one
would think that a new mother like
Shelby who actually adopted Puck's
biological daughter would have more
sense than to risk getting her child
taken away but no as soon as Puck sings
Waiting for a Girl Like You to her all
reason goes out the window and she
kisses him their difference in age isn't
the only contentious part of their
relationship Shelby is also Puck's
teacher which he poignantly highlights
by performing Van Halen's Hot for
Teacher in class on the one hand Puck is
desperate to be a dad to Baby Beth and
likes the idea of having an instant
family he starts making advances toward
Shelby soon after she allows him to see
Beth unfortunately she loves the
attention he gives her and isn't keen on
the single mom dating scene so she
barely pushes back watching Puck brag to
her about his sexual prowess is almost
as uncomfortable as watching them kiss
unable to be the adult in the room sh be
ultimately leaves altogether in search
of a new life facing zero consequences
for being a newly minted
Predator how many times does someone
need to get fired for fraternizing with
students before they get the picture for
Gossip Girl teacher Rachel Carr the
answer is unclear given that she teaches
students about Shakespeare you'd think
she might be more in tune with the
unhappy ending she sets herself up for M
Carr gets fired for creepily hanging out
with Dan in a way that doesn't seem
particularly healthy to the school's
Administration however instead of
proving them wrong and keeping things
innocent with Dan she immediately throws
caution to the wind and Strikes up an
actual relationship with her nerdy
student of course in a Shakespearean
twist of fate Miss Carr gets rehired but
doesn't end her affair with Dan instead
she takes their teacher student bond to
the next level by giving him a key to
her place with a handwritten note given
how he did their relationship gets it's
probably for the best that she comes to
her senses while getting intimate with
her student in a costume closet
realizing what she's doing she does the
responsible thing and opts to leave the
school and go home to Iowa leaving Dan
in peace why women kill takes the sugarm
mama Dynamic to the next level Rita
Castillo gave up her youth to marry a
rich man out of a belief that she would
inherit his wealth upon his death though
the old-timer foils her plan by staying
alive it's the role you hired me for
with Rita's own husband decades her
senior the resentful housewife takes a
leaf out of his book and finds a young
play thing of her own ritaa manipulates
struggling actor scooter polarski into
doing her bidding slowly but steadily
entrapping him though she has nothing
but contempt for her husband she mimics
his behavior in her treatment of scooter
everything between the pair is a
negotiation and not an especially Fair
one Rita uses her wealth and status as a
weapon making it impossible for scooter
to get out of their relationship every
kiss between these two reminds fans that
she's caging him and it's more than a
little tough to watch most horrifyingly
Rita refuses to let Scooter have any
relationships of his own while treating
him like a possession rather than a
partner on community middle-aged Jeff
Winger spends his entire friendship with
college student Annie Edison talking
about how she's too young for him yet he
frequently implies she's irresistible
and that he has no choice but to give
into her charms at every turn Jeff
ping-pongs between interest and
disinterest in a very uncomfortable way
and while Annie may not actually be
underage a 10 to 15E age Gap is
incredibly suspect when the younger
party is an 18-year-old the fact that
the characters involved are keenly aware
that the dynamic isn't okay makes it
somehow even worse to witness shouldn't
have brought it up just reminded me of
my dad anyway uh little make got 101
less dad talk Jeff and Annie have a
total of eight kisses in the series and
they're all pretty gross the power EMB
balance just never gets out of the way
and makes their will they want they
relationship sketchy at best it doesn't
help that the show also can't quite
resist sexualizing Annie even as it
jokes about that very thing Annie's
pretty young we try not to sexualize
her I'm sorry
whoo how could we have a list of
predatory romances without mentioning
Chef Jeff raycraft the skevy boss who
hires people so he can try to sleep with
them in Switched at Birth while Jeff may
not realize that his Paramore Daphne
Vasquez is a high school student when he
gets involved with her it's certainly
not the underaged teenagers
responsibility to prevent adults from
taking advantage of her even if she were
the college student he assumes she is
the Dynamics are still off considering
he's her boss Chef Jeff is a fully grown
adult and the head chef of a classy
restaurant that kind of position
requires a certain amount of experience
that a dyed teenager just doesn't have
yet even after Jeff discovers that
Daphne is still in high school he
doesn't push her away in the backstock
room when she comes on to him instead he
opts to make out with a teenager in
their place of business luckily deh's
friends and family don't normalize this
relationship so the show itself isn't
framing this strange coupling in a
positive light Barney Stinson of How I
Met Your Mother has an Infamous Playbook
which is essentially a how-to guide to
trick women into sleeping with him and
his favorite Pastime is trolling bars
for drunk women who are barely legal if
that in fact he even has a test to
decide whether or not a woman is too old
to sleep with to gauge their age he asks
if they think ewoks in Star Wars are
cute if they do they were probably
pretty young when the movie came out
which means they're young enough to be
attractive to him they reminded you of
our teddies they reminded you of your
teddies his creepiness doesn't end there
if Barney's not getting young women
plastered before sleeping with them he's
filming them during sex without their
consent or knowledge he also uses
hundreds of ploy to attract them like
pretending to be a dying man or figing a
ridiculous time travel story as a result
nearly every kiss Barney has in the show
is another step towards his place on the
sex offender registry his whole changed
mantick at the end of the series just
isn't believable after all of the
nastiness he displays in the Years
leading up to the
change intimacy between Mortal humans
and ageless vampires tends to feel less
taboo because there isn't a visually
obvious age Gap one classic example of
this phenomena is Angel and Buffy from
the cult classic TV series Buffy the
Vampire Slayer at first glance angel
looks like a college student yet the
reality is much more Sinister Buffy is a
16-year-old dating a 269 year-old
reformed serial killer to make matters
worse Angel knowingly seeks out Buffy to
relieve the persistent guilt of his past
by supposedly protecting her though it
looks a lot more like stocking from the
outside though Angel puts up minimal
resistance to Buffy's initial Crush he
never comes clean about his identity
until the truth emerges in season 1
instead of having a serious conversation
he terrifies her when his vampire face
emerges while they're hooking up then
rather than explain himself Angel throws
himself out of her window leaving Buffy
betrayed and Confused sure Buffy has to
grow up way faster than any teen should
but this relationship is all kinds of
shady and controlling even after Angel
breaks up with her in season 3 Buffy's
Watcher Gile really should have done
more to convince Angel to stop their
relationship before it began as an
important Father Figure in Buffy's life
he really seemed to slack off by letting
his pseudo daughter develop a
relationship with a centuries old
Predator fans of The Vampire Diaries
either love or hate Damon Salvatore but
no matter which way you sway there's
just no excusing what he does to
Caroline Forbes in season 1 in this
universe vampires can mystically compel
people to follow their desires it
doesn't take a genius to realize that
there can't be any kind of consent to
sexual activity when someone is quite
literally capable of controlling your
mind Damon wastes no time getting creepy
in episode two he aggressively bites
Caroline's neck igniting their one-sided
relationship over the course of their
time together Damon uses abuses and
ultimately discards the sheriff's
daughter not only is she 16 years old
making her well over 100 years Damon's
Jr Damon actively talks down to her when
they're together making her feel that
much more awful about the situation on
some level she doesn't even know what
she's upset about because he's toying
with her mind and muddling her memories
Damon isn't the only creepy vampire
around either Stefan starts a
relationship with Elena without telling
her his age vampire status or the fact
that he's stalking her because she looks
like his allegedly dead ex yesh vampires
suck in general but that
[Music]
sucks